JANET RANKIN: The
think-pair-share strategy
is one of the classic
active learning strategies
that one can use
in one's classes.
And it has, as you might
guess, three parts-- the think,
the pair, and the share.
Often there's a collapsing
of the pair and the share.
But in general, you
first give students
time to think about a
question or a situation
or some other scenario that
you want them to think about.
And you give them time to think
actively but alone about that.
And often you can ask them
to write down their thoughts.
But then at the end of
that short period of time,
whether it's three
minutes or five minutes,
you have them pair up.
And if it's a really big class
or the numbers of students
in your class warrant it,
you can have them triple up,
it doesn't have to be a pair.
And they discuss whatever
it is they came up with.
It's just an opportunity
for them to just say here,
this is what I thought of.
What did you think about it?
What did you think
about what I said?
So it's just an interactive
opportunity for the students
to hear from their peers.
And then the key part when
they're talking to each other
is that the instructor
should walk around
the room and kind of eavesdrop
on what the students are
saying.
So you want to understand
the kinds of things
they're talking about, maybe
not the specific details,
but the kinds of things
they're talking about.
And pretty quickly you
can learn if students
are on the right track or if
there's a big misconception
that maybe they
might be reinforcing
each other's misconceptions.
So you want to know
that as the instructor.
So that's why if possible,
to walk around the room
and just overhear what
people are saying,
that can be a really important
part of that pair step.
And then for the share,
you have them report out.
So this does two things.
One, it lets you bring to light
any specific comments that you
overheard during
the pair section.
You can bring it up
with the whole class,
because there can be
some really important,
wonderful observations the
students make within the pair.
And if you don't share that, or
if you don't create a situation
where that can be shared
with the bigger class,
then everybody misses out
except for those three people.
So it gives you an
opportunity to do that.
It also gives you an
opportunity to globally
clear up any
misconceptions that you've
heard that have bubbled up
from this pair exercise.
The other thing it
does is if there's
a group of two or
three or even four,
but I think three
is probably optimal,
the group reports as a group.
It doesn't report
as an individual.
So if a student is
a little insecure
or may not really want to
share what he or she thinks
at a personal level or
at an individual level,
being able to share out
as a group is a bit safer,
is a bit more comfortable
for many students.
So that's what the
share part does.
And then it just gets
the whole group together,
and it lets you kind of sum
up the smaller conversations
with the larger group.